Hello, Citizen Turn members.
Chesley Morning Brief with the Happy Investment Chairman
.  Friday, July 3rd. Ah, we will
begin with some of the program leading up to the weekend.   The
Korean market was very bad yesterday, and as
we will talk about with Yuripro later, it
seems the US market wasn't very good either.  Let's take a look at the situation in the Chinese market
.  I have a request for you, Manager Wang
. Yes,
yesterday, the
upper limit index also
dropped a little over 2% due to global synchronization.  The Heungseung Tag Index
dropped 0.4% to 4% and
maintained a level of 3.5 trillion when regular time was reached.   If
you look at the sectors, I learned that yesterday, the materials and consumer
goods sector was strong, while the IT,
communications, and business sectors were weak
.
Trading dividend stocks
went up a bit yesterday due to an influx of funds buying at low prices.  Batter Choi Won
rose by 1%, Chunggu Shinhwa rose by 3%, and Jeong
rose by 1%.   The
price of Beolja is rebounding again these days
.  So, for this reason, the material Kwon Yeon-ju
Eose has come up.  Funding went
up by 4.5% to 5%, material costs by
3%, and electric vehicle funding by 7% to 5%
.  Machinery-related stocks rebounded following the release of machinery export data
.  Semil used prices went up by +2%, and
Seogong machinery prices went up by 3.23%.
Recently, there has been continuous talk regarding the increase in demand for air conditioners in the European market
.
Driven by this expectation, the government-run household stock market
has reversed course.  Transaction home appliances rose 1.4%
.  Hayeol home appliances rose by 0.5% and
5%, while Semajiguk rose by 1.6%
.  After the Taebaek company's earnings
announcement, the stock price continues to rise
.  Oh, for Soonbong Holdings, inflammation came out at 7%,
full pain relief at 3.5%, and new pain relief at
3.6%.  Meanwhile, consumer goods-
related stocks also showed relative strength yesterday
.  Guizo Mate is 0.8%,
Hardirer is 4%, Citrine is 2%, and Xin
China is 0.5%. I couldn't scoop them out and came back.
This time, Hong Kong Tag stocks showed a slight rebound yesterday
.  Ari Paba rose 1.8%
.  Biwadi rose by 8%,
Liuto by 1.7%, and Shop by 2.3%
.  However, Kwon Hyung-ju of A was completely
out yesterday.  The manners
dropped by 7.5%.  Joytech decided to have a Manners
10%, the park 8%, the
5th company 6.5%, and Heojeon
Jungsin also 10%
.  New Year's replacement rate opening
inflammation 8b line.  The specific yield
rate rose by 5bp, and the foreign
exchange rate was 0.09%
.   hmm.
thank you  yes.
Uh, I think the phrase "global stock market synchronization" is
one of the things you repeat the most.  It goes
without saying, and looking at China yesterday, the
Shanghai Index, Shenzhen Index, and
CSI 300 rarely fluctuate by more than 1%, but
yesterday, they all seemed to have dropped quite significantly, by about 2% or 3%
.  Manager, based on mainland China,
is the upper and lower limit 10%?  Well,
looking at the basic point in time,
companies like the Super Index and Shinjeon Index
are fluctuating by plus or minus 10%.
You know the second half of the youth group.  That's correct, plus or
minus 20%
20% for the spores to start
.
Hong Kong has
no sleeping place.   does
n't exist.  Well, just like in the US, it could
go up 50%, or maybe
70%.
So, yesterday, Korea was doing
very poorly, mainly driven by memory stocks. I
thought China might have also faced a 10% drop across the board, including things like CCL and copper foil.
But looking here, Hojin and
Joytech are both 10%, and yes, it seems
calmer than Korea. So,
am I wrong?   You
know, the
situation where the Maebly company is still not in Hansanjong right now.
So, since this is different from the existing ones, you need to keep a close
eye on it.
CCR PCB companies account for almost 10% of the
early admissions, right?  It
dropped a bit by 10% yesterday, you know.
The casting is also similar.  The feeling is exactly the
same.
Well, CCR Holsan dropped about 8% on Manners, and
Success Tech dropped 6% on Manners
.  yes.  3. Actually, it's
similar to Samsung Electric.  It dropped by almost 13% yesterday as well
.  hmm.   hmm.
The trend is somewhat
similar.   hmm.
All right.
So, on the other side, the sectors or stocks that have consistently
suffered from supply and demand imbalances
seem to have performed relatively well, just as was the case in Korea.
That is correct.
Issue stock Nakdeok stock.   yes
.  Nak-si has done some research on this company a few times
.  However, the stock price has
risen a lot.  As for that April, the
atmosphere based on the retouch data was 3 trillion at that time
.  Now it's the 8th group.
So, I’ve set it aside for almost a month or two
.   I was
also the manufacturer of the maximum battery
usage bar.  It holds a
30% market share globally and is ranked No. 1 globally.   The
KEPPAN is currently around 150,000, and the
cost for PCBs is almost 30,000
.  The actual first quarter saw the Jeonse listing
.  Sales increased by 80% compared to the same period
.  The profit was in the surplus.
Uh, the GP margin for the first game is 11.7%
.  Compared to the same period and the previous quarter, both
expanded, and the MP margin was recorded at 1.58%, marking a
profit. The
QQ also rose by 0.8% to 8%
. There are
exactly two reasons for these strong results
.  The first is the Micron after midnight and the
lower-tier Donbak. This part
accounts for about 10%. We are expanding the weight of this section,
and the
hatching year for PCB sperm Donbak is increasing
.  So [clears throat] the
actual performance of the two of you turned out well.  Especially
that PCB company-use Dongbang, you know.   The
non-validation rate is currently 30%
.
Due to factors such as increased demand for electric vehicle batteries and expanded production capacity, the demand for Donba is
expected to increase by 29% year-on-year and by more than 20% year-on-year
.  On the other hand, there has been almost
no capacity increase in upgrades over the past few years
.  It has been reduced.  Or maybe because it keeps running at a
deficit.  So originally, the
supply system may be limited, and next year, only about
13% can be set at the regular price.
So, the industry's capacity utilization has already
risen to the 93% level, and
there is a possibility of further increases next year. This
refurbished capacity utilization could probably
go up to 97% next year.
[Snoring] Uh, Dongsan is currently only
distributing about 15 million won, and
together with Gup, the Dongmae Bijo is expected to see the fee increase from 25% last year
to 50% this year.   As for
the pants, last year there is a possibility that the inflammation will expand beyond just the level of the Manners inflammation
.
Looking at the report submitted by Dongwoo, they suggested maintaining a
buy recommendation based on the simultaneous demand for batteries, donba, and sperm
.  Originally,
next year's marriage ranking
was estimated to be around 2.12 billion for Your
Excellency, with an increase of 30% compared to 20%, 145%, and 1.22 billion
.  If you reverse oxidize, the
original budget is about 38 times
.  There is only 16 times for next year and
12 times for the year after.
When Eum Holsa is doing well, well, you can
get roughly 20 PRs.
So, I also did PR for the 20th session next year, and the
TP
came out to about 9, which is kind of... well, something.  Compared to yesterday's closing price, it could be
up 30%.
However, this company's report just did
n't present a benchmark.   hmm.  uh
.  Usually, these are growth stocks in China,
and regarding stocks related to CCL, which is one of the terms most frequently mentioned recently...
yes.  Uh, as far as I remember, the
multiple was applied as a target multiple of about 30 times [clears throat] or even higher. But the fact that
Manager Wang applied around 20 times now—is that because the
upstream industry is
automotive batteries?  Why is
that? Um... regarding this
improvement, I made that car battery,
that thing for batteries, a money bar.
Because the determination is so fierce, the margin doesn't
come out.  It was just right.   It is already
constantly being upgraded, so if you look here, you can see that there
is Jawoo Micron.
This is a complete refusal, and it even went up
to Donba.  The one below didn't
come out.  So, the margins in this area are
continuing, and especially recently,
regarding those PCBs for sperm, you know they keep making money
.  This has a high profit margin.   yes
.
So, in the short term, this weighting is still
not high.  If you do the whole thing, it's
about 50%.  So the remaining
50% is still my low-priced product.   If you apply a
strong bet here, it’s a bit ambiguous, but I
think it’s not bad to apply a small bet here.
All right.  yes.   uh
.  Even though they are the same copper foil manufacturers, is the profit margin under sales determined by the upstream industry
and the
specific value-added area of ​​the product
?
Ah, regarding the operating rate, the strange thing is that
in China's Energy 3, we don't look at the English usage rate; we
only look at the ranking rate. Um, since you might be
looking at the table in the bottom left,
there are six lines; let me
briefly explain what they are starting from the top.  First, the
sales revenue;
second, the year-over-year
growth rate of out-of-year spending;
next, the ranking; next, the year-over-year
growth rate; and then
EPS. That's correct. The next one is correct.
Understood.
You won't be able to
remember again next time.  I'll ask again
.  [Laughs]
Yes.  All right.
thank you  That is as far as
we look at the Chinese market.  It seems the US market wasn't very good yesterday, so let's take a look at it
with YuriPro
.   yes
.  As you mentioned, continuing from yesterday, the
sentiment took a somewhat negative turn
.  It has really only been two days since the second half began, but the
CAPEX debate sparked by Meta [clears throat] has
reignited the fire, and it was Thursday in the
US market.
If you look at the index first, [clearing throat]
SB closed almost flat.
And now, as for the Bow Index, it
rose 1.1%, becoming the
only one to break its all-time high for two consecutive trading days
.  On the other hand, the Nasdaq
fell by 1.6%, and the Philippine
index plummeted by about 5%.
Now, looking at the 5-day period, it
has dropped by about 4% to 9.4%.  Now, if we were to
simply say that yesterday's market was "risk-happy," as far as
I know,
Bitcoin should have fallen along with it.
However, looking at the data, Bitcoin
and Gold rose together, albeit slightly, and the Dow
also
hit a new high. Therefore,
rather than the entire market collapsing, I think we can get the impression that the
debate over AI CAPEX recovery rates sparked by Meta caused a
concentrated de-rating in the AI ​​infrastructure supply chain
.
Now, continuing to the bottom, if you look at the text at the bottom, there was an
employment indicator announcement yesterday
.  First of all, the increase in employment in February was
limited to about 57,000 people.  It was weaker than market expectations
.  Also, as it was
revised downward again compared to the previous two months, it seems to reflect the assessment that the
momentum for employment recovery has cooled down somewhat recently.
As for the labor participation rate, it fell from 4.2% to
2%, but
since this was influenced by a drop in the labor participation rate rather than a strong job market, it is difficult to view it
as a positive market in terms of employment indicators
.  It goes back and forth a bit, but if you
move to the top right, we will
now look at the interest rates.
Now, the first thing the market reacted to due to these employment indicators was the
2-year
yield.  So,
if you look at the deferred government bond yield, it is 4.14%, so it
fell by 3.7b.  Now, the 2-year
yield is, after all, the most immediate indicator of the Fed's policy funds
.  So, as
employment figures came out somewhat weaker than expected, it appears that the
interpretation is that the need for the Fed to take immediate action beyond what is needed has diminished
.  One
important point here seems to be that the 10-year government bond yield has
not fallen significantly along with it
.  Continuing from yesterday, the New Year's price remained
almost unchanged at around 4.48%, and
if you look at the flow of the image at the top, it has
risen slightly.
So, the fact that the 2-year yield fell means that while the
pressure for further hikes by the Fed has
eased due to the slowdown in employment, the 10-year yield was either bearish or somewhat
affected.  Looking at the overall trend,
long-term inflation, fiscal issues,
and the
burden of capital costs—AI and CAPEX, which are the main keywords of today—remain somewhat
unresolved.  So, the overall trend was that interest rates could not
comfortably drop
.   If you look at it
by industry, this
trend becomes a bit clearer.  While
the lowering of interest rates helped
support the market bottom, the 10-year bond remained at a
high level,
leaving some burden regarding the debate over the recovery of AI CAPEX
.  So, as a result, there
was a rotation from tech stocks to healthcare and then to defensive stocks.  The index fell a bit as the IT
sector dropped by about 1.5%
.  Communication
and the consumer freedom system were weaker.
Conversely, the healthcare sector
showed an upward trend,
rising most significantly from 2.7% to 7%, while consumer
staples increased by 2.4% and utilities by
2.3%.  So, it seems that SP was able to remain somewhat stable as the
healthcare, consumer staples, and finance sectors absorbed the volume lost from the IT sector
.
So, if you look at the 52-week highs, you will
see that they are
centered around healthcare rather than semiconductors, which have appeared frequently in the past
.  Now, if
you look at the middle section, there were a total of 49 new
stocks. I
analyze these based on which sector appears the most when I make a move.  And regarding the upward trend, if
you look at it, more than half
came from the finance and healthcare sectors.   As
I mentioned at the bottom, out of the 49 stocks that hit new highs,
there were 16 in finance and 13 in healthcare, so it was
definitely a day where the finance and healthcare sectors
hit many new highs.
Now, looking at the stocks in the middle section,
Moderna rose by about 10%,
Vertex by 6%, and Davita by 4%, showing an
upward trend in the healthcare sector
.  In the financial sector,
Visa and Allstate recorded new highs, and in the
IT sector,
CrowdStrike was the only complementary stock to also
hit a new high. It appears that
stocks like CrowdStrike and Palo Networks are continuing to
attract attention as security remains a key issue in the LLM model.
Within healthcare, the bio sector saw a significant
rise.  Now, in the case of Moderna, there
was a portfolio re-evaluation regarding cancer and vaccines following COVID-19; in the
case of Vertex,
there was an approval for an expanded new drug related to digestive indications; and in the
case of FB, it received more policy benefits, and it is said that the
Trump administration mentioned
passing regulations regarding hospital drugs
.
When looking at what this entails, the general trend was to implement policies designed to allow Medicare
Part B patients to save approximately $800 annually. Consequently,
when considering the competitive landscape between hospitals and pharmaceutical companies, this administrative approach appears to reduce hospitals' margins while
directly increasing those margins for pharmaceutical firms. This has led
to a positive outlook for pharmaceutical stocks, with
major companies like Johnson & Johnson—though not listed in the official records—showing
strength.  So, because
these large pharmaceutical stocks are strong and have large
market capitalizations, the healthcare sector has
benefited from policy measures.   I
mentioned that Visa and Allstate hit new highs in the financial sector.
As you will explain, Visa's performance reflects
defensive growth in payment networks, while
Allstate's performance
reflects the strong performance of insurance stocks from the previous session.  If
you look at it this way, you could say that semiconductors and
IT are falling, and continuing from
yesterday, there is sector broadening in the financial sector. However,
rather than fixating on this sector broadening, it
was a market where stocks with individual catalysts, while somewhat detached from the AI ​​CAPEX debate, reached new highs and showed a positive trend.
If you move to the left side of the Big Tech section, the main character
was in the meta yesterday.  In the case of Menta,
there were reports yesterday that they are considering a cloud infrastructure business to sell AI computing power and model access rights externally.  So, as it
rose by about 8% yesterday,
the news was initially interpreted somewhat positively by Meta
.  On the other hand, it has
fallen by about 5% today.  I would like to discuss the issue of why this
trend continues
.  Now, companies
like Meta and Big Tech have already
invested massive amounts in AI infrastructure.
Now, in such a situation, if you can sell some computing
capacity externally, it can be seen as
increasing the return on invested capital (ROIC). So,
Meta rose a bit yesterday,
but I thought that in just one day, the
market might have raised a more fundamental question
.  The question is likely, "
Then why should we sell this?"
To understand this, I
think we need to look at Meta's existing business structure. Regarding AI, Meta's
existing business does
not monetize AI by selling the AI ​​itself like an API; its core business is optimizing
advertising efficiency.
So, it is a recommendation structure designed to increase
dwell time and ad conversion rates on Facebook, Instagram, and Reels through AI recommendation rankings, and
further boost sales conversions by recommending corporate customer consultations within WhatsApp and Instagram through AI business AI and commerce
.  So,
regarding Meta's existing AI monetization,
advertising was the core business, and business
AI and commerce
were expansion options. On the other hand, regarding
the demand for AI cloud, which they are viewing as a new upside, it involves
selling to external markets
.  Therefore,
rather than being a core business focused on increasing internal efficiency, it appears to be an indicator closer to an option requiring
additional capital recovery to boost the return rate of this expanded AI CAPEX
.  So,
the dimension required for this is likely an
expansion of GPU clusters for training and computing capacity for output, and well, that is
necessary.  It is a given that it is
necessary for inference and learning,
but the issue
seems to be the scale of investment.
Generally speaking, when we look at selling effective computational resources,
selling effective computational resources
can be interpreted to mean that some of the already secured influence remains and that the plan is to increase the utilization rate of those assets
.  However, you might think that the
fact that this remains means it is no longer needed, but at the same time,
Meta
has signed an infrastructure contract with Coreweave worth $21 billion through 2022.  And it looks like they are
continuing to aggressively secure capacity, to the extent that they have even signed a 1.6GW contract with Crusoe
.
Then, now there are plenty of resources
left.  However, they continue to invest. Considering that these
two facts are proceeding simultaneously, I
think we can make a prediction like this for now.
If you are really selling leftover capacity,
why are you constantly securing additional capacity?   hmm.
And conversely, if securing additional capacity continues to be
necessary, doesn't that mean that external sales—that is, relying solely on the existing
AI revenue, or the existing business
model—will make it difficult to quickly and sufficiently demonstrate a return on investment
?  So, I think we can simultaneously raise the question of whether the existing business model has been
compromised
.  So,
looking at Ecoive's $21 billion figure,
personally, I wonder if their
existing internal business model isn't
generating enough revenue to cover this deal?  So,
considering that this $21 billion is a minimum benchmark, whether they can
now earn more than that from cloud revenue will
likely serve as an indicator to evaluate Meta's future direction.
Additionally, if you look into the semiconductor sector as
well, this interpretation suggests that it didn't stop at just one meta
.  I have been saying repeatedly that there are
sides making money and sides spending money. If
the meta
has fallen like this today, then conversely, a trend where the profit-making side—such as
semiconductors—should have risen should have
occurred simultaneously. However,
contrary to that, the semiconductor trend continued to
fall, just like yesterday.  So, when the market
observed this trend, it appears to have moved
beyond the interpretation that Big Tech is not making money and taken a
step further to consider whether the problem lies with AI itself or the AI ​​capital expenditures
.  So, the
important point here is that the memory
shortage is being continuously mentioned; the
fact is that the lack of memory supply is due to the continued strong demand for AI
.  So, while the phenomenon of the memory shortage
itself has not disappeared, with
memory and B-tech currently
declining, from the perspective of market investors, the
shortage phenomenon has effectively
vanished.
Rather than saying that the AI ​​phenomenon itself has disappeared,
moving on to the next question, I think we can
now
verify in the direction of market investments and stock prices whether this shortage can continue to justify the growth rate of Big Tech CAPEX
.   yes
.  So, to
offer another twist, I believe the key question for the second half of the year will be how to interpret these various simultaneous
phenomena and
how to view the subsequent developments.
Therefore, identifying whose
revenue and cash flow the invested Captex will generate more quickly,
whose debt and cost
burden it will ultimately become,
or whether there are other growth sectors available, will likely
be the core of today's and yesterday's market trends.  That's all.
thank you  Looking at my eldest uncle's records, I do
n't really remember the index drop of around 15% during the bull market.  Is it a year, perhaps?   It happens once
every two years.  So,
since there are always significant corrections even in a bull market, I have been repeatedly emphasizing the need to distinguish whether the bull market trend is
reversing or if it is merely a
temporary correction.
Usually, when calculating the decline rate in such a bull market and
stating how many times a year a decline occurs by a certain percentage, the
standard is always the SMP
500.  However, based on the SMP 500
standard, there is currently absolutely no adjustment of more than 10% or anything like that
.  Right?
However, since we have
recently been focusing only on AI-related stocks in the Philadelphia Semiconductor Index, I feel like
the market is collapsing. If
this could be
applied to general indices as well, we could have
a little more confidence that we might enter a bull market again, but
I am not sure if it applies to these sub-indexes
.  So,
since you are investing heavily in semiconductors, you must be
feeling the current market situation is even more serious
.  It seems correct that we have reached a turning point regarding whether
our existing investment portfolio can
recover in this area once again
.  We will
continue to provide updates on that part while
looking at the US market.  It's
not Korea, right?  I'm going to try switching to virtual assets, and they aren't
bad
.  If you look only at the flow of the day,
what about the evening?   yes
.  To be honest, the virtual market wasn't
bad.  And it actually
looked quite good.  Actually, since the
price of Bitcoin has been affected a lot and
dropped significantly during that time, I am not sure if I should consider it a good thing, but I
think the decisive factor yesterday was after the non-farm payrolls data was released
.  As the employment index fell significantly lower
than expected,
people began to have
expectations that the pressure to raise interest rates might have eased, and I understand that the
probability of a freeze has actually surged on PadWatch
.
So, as a result, the monthly index also
came down, and as I will briefly
introduce below, short-term rates also
dropped a bit. I think these factors
had a positive impact on the price of Bitcoin. At the same time,
since precious metals like gold and silver also rose, I believe yesterday's issue provided a bit more justification
.  So, I
think I can explain it technically as well.  If
you look at the long-term Bitcoin chart on the right, you
can see the point where it simply touched that line lightly once and came down.  Now, the
200-day moving average has always been used as an indicator of the bottom
.  I previously mentioned that it has historically acted this way, and
yesterday it touched the 200-day moving average
once and then
showed signs of coming back down a little.  Since it is in the
range of around $62,000, you
can refer to that range. Also,
since Bitcoin's valuation is not determined by performance or anything like that, it is very often decided by technical
movements, historical highs and lows, and
historical patterns
.  So, I think it would be
good for you to keep in mind that this 200-day moving average can serve as a highly symbolic meaning for Bitcoin in a situation where it is not being valued, and to use this as a reference for your investments
.
If you look at the Bitcoin Huynh Grade Index, the extreme fear zone is
still recording 11, and if
you look at the net outflow of the Bitcoin spot ETF, it is still recording an outflow trend
.
I saw that there has been an outflow for more than 10 days and it is continuing. It seems that the bad trend is continuing, with an outflow of about 300 million
yesterday and on July 1st.   As
I briefly mentioned above,
non-governmental employment fell
significantly short of expectations.  So, as a result, the
highest interest rates plummeted
.  So, Bitcoin rose, and the
dollar index narrowed slightly,
showing a sharp drop as well.  So, it seems safe to say that various factors played a
significant role in Bitcoin's rise.
Now, as I refer to various on-chain
data, I see that
liquidity, market
makers, and other diverse aspects are
currently very dry.
So, personally, I think that yesterday's
rise in Bitcoin was not a sudden surge, but rather a
general upward trend followed by a pattern of blocking a resistance line and coming back down
.  It seems that I have been
providing brief guidance on institutional matters since yesterday
.  As I explained on the right, the
MICA bill dominates the paperwork in Europe. The
MICA
bill is a European bill that has been pushed forward for over 23 years and has
continuously gone through a period of postponement
.  So,
doing Margin Cryptos regulation like this is called
Milpa.  So, to put it simply, the
protection of these investors has become very
strong.  This kind of thing would be a
very bad issue for business owners or people who run businesses using assets.  Because,
originally, the process was supposed to proceed by using the money provided by those who intended to invest to make other investments, but I
think it would be easiest to understand the Mika bill as a bill where the money does not circulate.  The most representative
clause of the MICA bill is that assets entrusted by customers
must be perfectly stored on a one-to-one basis
.  And there is a bill that requires
about 60% of the changed cash to be entrusted
to local banks, such as regional banks in Europe
.
Therefore, as a result, in the case
of Tether, the USDT I mentioned yesterday, they have
completely abandoned their license in Europe
.  So, we gave up on Rice and are
currently distributing USDT, but
what are we going to do if a massive sell-off occurs and people all go to local banks asking for their money?  You
can view the closure of the European business as Tether, considering it a very significant risk. If you look at that, you might immediately
get a hint: the indirect beneficiary is
USD DC.
Therefore, in the stablecoin market where a reflection of the Circle
can actually occur,
the bill that allows for the Circle's reflection of the Circle is the MICA bill.  So, if you
look at the reports related to the circle, you'll see that
stories about Mika keep coming up, and you'll understand that it happened that way
within this flow of events
.  So, I think it would be easiest for you to just think of it as the leading business operator
withdrawing from Europe
.
There is also one of the largest companies.  Oh, if
you look at the very bottom left, you will see Binance.
Binance has also practically shut down its business in Europe because it was
unable to obtain a license there
.
So, although they have announced that they will acquire the business, you can understand that they are
currently
unable to conduct business in Europe. The
reason I mentioned Binance is that it is the
world's largest
cryptocurrency exchange, possessing the largest number of users and a massive amount of assets under custody, so you
can view that as a bit of a concern. However, USDT and
Binance have something in common.  Usually, the
common point is that both are Chinese Hong Kong-based capital.  It’s
not that Chinese capital is opaque, but
Binance and the investment firm
were somewhat less cooperative when it came to complying with current regulations.  So, you can
interpret it as follows: virtual reality (VR) operators like Circle, Coinbase, or Kraken have put in a tremendous amount of effort to secure market share in Europe so that they can continue their business there.
I think I can wrap things up by mentioning the last two points.  Uh, regarding this title, I just came
across a bit of an interview with Son Heung-min.  I mentioned yesterday that Open
Standard
issued a stablecoin
.  Actually, the issuance hasn't even
started yet; we just said
we would do it as a consortium.  You can interpret this as A
Circle signing an infrastructure contract yesterday
with a bank called Standardized to distribute USDC
.  So, they say that
Standard Charles is
part of the banking sector known as G.  G is said to be on the
cold list among the banks in the United States that are specially managed
.  So, the banks on the
list included in the GB are the largest major banks that are managed separately because the U.S. bears the risk that they must
not fail due to their sheer size.
Specifically, the U.S. mandates that these banks
increase their reserve requirements
or enforces a specific ratio of government bond purchases
in the GC
.  So,
Circle was
using Coinbase and various other
exchanges as intermediaries to distribute the stablecoin called USDC. You can view this as
Standard Chartered partnering with Circle to act as an intermediary, enabling
other companies and
banks to distribute and use USDC.
Therefore,
from the perspective of companies like Open USD, this was
not particularly good news.  And from
Circle Circle's perspective, although there was a very long
explanation yesterday, they have now expanded the channels for distributing
USC—that is, stablecoins—even within the institutional framework
.  You can
consider it that kind of news.   On
the right,
I brought a news report stating that Trump continued to grow his assets through virtual assets even in 2025.
There was news from Reuters that Trump earned about $1.4 billion last year from crypto-related business units.  Trump did
officially deny it today, though
.  Anyway, they actually conducted
asset inspections and investigations on the President and Vice President
one by one
.  A related report has
been released, and that is the
table at the bottom right.  If you look at the bottom right,
there is also USDC, the stablecoin I just mentioned.  There is Ethereum, and
then there is also things like Bitcoin
.
The report actually stated that there are a great many assets holding that.  Uh, and the
one at the very bottom was a bit peculiar; it was
found that they earned a very large amount of royalties from something called Celebration Coin.
So, of course, you can consider it a lie if President Trump
claims he has no interest in virtual assets right now, and there are,
uh, a
great many conflicts of interest issues currently underway
.  You can understand that the ongoing conflicts—such as the one regarding Clitti Act, where
people question whether it makes sense to push
crypto-related projects while holding Clitti Crypto—are occurring against
this backdrop
.  That's all.
thank you  Today, it seems you have done a good job explaining
which systems and companies can provide updates regarding virtual assets
.  I will wrap up some [snorting] here
.  You must be
very worried as the market continues to show corrections
.  Thank you to everyone who joined us for Part 1. I will
provide more detailed information in Part 2.
Thank you to everyone at Cheton for being with us.  no see.
[Music]
เฮ
เฮ [Music]
[Music]
Hello.  The Happy Investment Journey will
begin with Part 2 of the Chasley Morning Brief today, Friday, July 3rd, with investment expert Chasley.
Now, the Philippine index has plummeted for two days.
Yes, that is correct.   hmm.   Although the
10-year international interest rate has risen slightly, the
overall market
SMP of 500 remains flat.
Yes, that is correct.
So, Philban is somewhat
heavily affected, so I suppose the meta had a
big impact, right?
yes.  I believe the meta has had a significant impact, and that
these events are
occurring in combination with rotations, leverage liquidations, liquidations of new long-term positions, and rebalancing, all using meta-driven issues as a pretext
.  So, as you mentioned, the cumulative decline over the past two days
is 11.4%.  It is 4%.  But if you
think about it carefully, the
beta of the index is high and heavily skewed,
so there have actually been quite a few instances this year where the cumulative
decline exceeded 10%
.  If
you look at the table below,
when the war took place in March of this year, the cumulative decline rate for March
was about 10%.  And then
in May, as interest rates and oil prices
surged, it dropped by about 6% in two days
.
And in early June, due to interest rates, the
SpaceX IPO, and various other issues, it
dropped 12% in just two days
.  And um, around
mid-June, due to the burden of short-term fruit
valuations—there was
no specific reason, but if I had to give one—it fell
1.9% because of issues like this
.  And
after finishing the first half, on July 1st,
during the 2nd trading day, it fell by 11.4% to 4%
.  So, I think the decline resulted from the accumulation of factors, including concerns that CAPEX might be reduced—which
stemmed from the Metacritic doll infrastructure controversy—plus
the stock market
overheating and the
spread of profit-taking and rebalancing demand across sectors amidst high margin trading
.  So, I thought the decline on the first day might have been
a bit of an overreaction, but you can
consider this as a further sharp drop
.
Yes, if you look at the Philippine Index EPS and P below, the
P multiple has dropped from 23.65x
to 65x
.  Oh, the EPS remained
unchanged.
Mizuo released a related comment, and I
generally tend to agree with it. I have been
continuously reviewing all the recent comments from the Ivys, and the
tone is pretty similar.
First off, regarding what has emerged from the U.S., the
assessment is that Meta’s consideration of directly selling cloud computing capacity, as reported by Bloomberg, is neither a signal of short-term commercialization nor a slowdown in investment; rather, the view in the U.S. is that it is correct to understand Meta’s
plan merely as a Plan B.  There are
two paths to realizing ROI in infrastructure investment: generating
revenue through proprietary AI products or
leasing capacity. In the case of Meta, since
most investors have
not yet envisioned reliable returns and avenues for that AI investment, we believe this review should be
interpreted as an expression of determination to increase ROI in one way or another
.
Yesterday, there was a reaction from the Bloomberg booth—or perhaps a comment from
Mark Zuckerberg at a town meeting—where he stated that they had been
developing an AI agent but it had
not progressed as expected.
According to what Zuckerberg revealed at the town meeting, the development of the AI ​​agent over the past four months has
not progressed as anticipated, and
furthermore, the reorganization of the company has
not proceeded smoothly, and the investments expected from the new organizational structure have
not yet borne fruit.  Judging by these comments, it
seems there was some internal deliberation regarding the benefits of investing in AI, and I think this
plan was announced as a kind of Plan B based on that deliberation
.
So, I
think it is difficult to [snor] that this part leads to the direction of AI or the reduction of CAPEX or anything like that.  And using that
as an excuse, I
think there was a sell-off across the entire Philippine index, which had risen by more than 100% during the first half of the year.  So, given that
these declines are
occurring frequently in the major indices due to high beta, and that
recent market concentration has been quite strong—and
that major fund surveys
show
trading was quite rough—I believe that while the
reason for the 11.4% drop over the past two days differs somewhat from previous declines, ultimately, the
controversy may ease and the market may recover.
However,
to achieve this, I
think it will be necessary to verify earnings and the guidance regarding CAPEX from big tech companies
.
So, looking at yesterday, there were many stocks in the Philippine index that
fell by double digits, and there were
no stocks that rose.  So,
overall, I
think that the expected selling pressure came out all at once
.
Because it fell by about 11% in a short period of double digits, and
considering the magnitude of the previous decline,
the parts that fell due to external factors... since a
pattern has emerged where it rebounds after dropping by that amount, [
snorting] I
think there might be a rebound here
.
June employment figures were released yesterday, and the
number of employed people in agriculture
increased by 57,000.  It increased to 129,000 last month,
but it was
a bit smaller compared to the previous month.  Professional office jobs
decreased by 36,000, West Sea welfare support by 25,000, healthcare by 22,000, and leisure eligibility by 61.  The leisure sector was a
bit high last month, but since that sector has decreased, it
seems that the overall growth in non-farm employment was lower compared to the previous month.  The experiment rate came out at 4.2%,
whereas it was 4.3% last month.
Looking at it,
there are parts that suggest there were few job losses and few layoffs,
but the economic activity participation rate
was only 61.5% and 5%.  It
was 61.8% in May.   It
was 8%.  So,
considering the decrease in the economic activity participation rate, I
think this experimental rate suggests that both body size and white weight were low.  So,
there are parts like the brake, un, and unim, and I
think this is an experimental rate that resulted from the process of these parts becoming thinner.
So, I checked how interest rate policy actually worked and
how prices were affected. The
Cleveland Institute of Economic Research continues to provide updates on the June and
July CPI and PC prices;
since the update was on July 2nd, I
assume it was updated yesterday. The CPI is expected to be
released around the middle of this month.   The
PC figures are set to be released around July 30th.
First, the headline CPI for May
was 4.2%.
Recently, Bloomberg and
the Cleveland Institute of Economic Research
had forecast around 4.0% for June, but
the market and the
Cleveland Institute are now
estimating that the June CPI will drop slightly to 3.9% or 9%.  We expect the July CPI to
drop a bit further to around 3.49% or 3.5%.  And
as for PCs, the figures were
4.1% in May,
3.9% in June, and
3.7% in July. As for Core PCs, the figures were
3.4%, 3.43%, and 3.447%, so the
market is currently viewing that Core PCs are unlikely to drop significantly
.  So,
perhaps because the non-farm payrolls were a bit lower than expected following the release of yesterday's employment figures,
FedWatch has
confirmed that the estimated probability of a freeze at the FMG meeting on July 29 is 82.4%.  It
increased slightly from 3% to 66.3% a week ago
.  So, the possibility itself can change depending on what the macro indicators
come out
.  Based on the indicators released so far, at
82.4% and 4%, the situation currently suggests that the
FMC on July 29th has
increased the likelihood of a freeze.
And
regarding the AI ​​utilization that Jeomun mentioned yesterday, I did some searching for articles, but I am
not sure if the article itself is accurate.  However, according to data
from VentureBeat, a research firm, which was
surveyed a month or two ago on May 8, 2026, the
utilization rate of corporate AI spending, particularly spending on GPUs, is only 5%.  Ah, there
was an article like this.  So,
according to the article, Gartner concluded, based on estimates from corporate
officials—specifically 53 in January and
39 in February—that the
average utilization rate of AI relative to corporate spending is only 5%. They are citing
reasons such as a
lack of data integration, insufficient internal readiness,
and failure to comply with company regulations
.
However, since the sample size is limited to about 40 out of 50 corporate officials, it is a
bit...
questionable. Anyway, this could be seen as a critique of the
AI ​​utilization by some companies—specifically,
cases where they have secured GPUs but don't know how to use them properly.
Currently,
among hyperscalers, Frontier Labs, and consumer enterprises, the
actual use of Frontier
Labs' Open AI, Entropic,
Google's Jamina, and similar tools by consumer companies,
as well as the utilization of
GPUs by configuring them or actually
securing and using them by enterprises,
seems to be concentrated on the hyperscaler side, but the
utilization in this area is lagging behind
expectations.  The expenditure
is insufficient.  I
think it suggests these kinds of things.
[Snoring] That's all.
What do you think of our Mr. Moon Seong-mu?   It
seems like the enterprise investment has started, but I can't deny that the in-house model
setup feels a bit lacking
.  It feels like I bought it but don't really
use it.  So, for now, it
seems they are using the leading models available in the cloud.
You know a bit about what kind of person Zuckerberg is, right?
Zuckerberg is very aggressive and yes.   It is
challenging, and that is
correct.
yes.  He is that kind of person, and there have been cases where he previously spent
a lot of money trying to do something called the metaverse,
but later, when it did
n't produce the desired results, he reduced costs
and streamlined the organization
.
yes.
I share exactly the same thought, and I even
told my son the same thing last night. If you look at Zuckerberg, he is
very aggressive and has a
style of taking the lead.   Because they have a
style of charging ahead, regarding the
creation of the native market for the metaverse in the second half of 2021—well, rather than saying they
created it—it was Facebook that
strengthened the narrative a bit more at that time. They declared, "This is the
world ahead,"
changed the name to Meta, and back then, they hired absolute beginner
programmers and junior programmers for as little as
$300,000 to drive up
labor costs, and they just went all out in that direction.
But before that, if you look at that emerging VR machine, you know
.  As for that VR device,
Meta already acquired Oculus back in 2011 or 2012 for
11.4 trillion won, so that was already about
15 years ago
.
yes.  That is correct.  yes.   It is a
style of being very fast and aggressive toward such innovative things, but even with
Oculus VR, it has
been 15 years and there hasn't been much to see, and the same was true for the
Metaverse
.  yes.   They just went all out, and
because of that, the
stock price dropped by about 75% in 2022.
In Facebook's ecosystem,
money flows in steadily as it acts as a stable cash cow.  The ads are like that again.   hmm.
But they kept recklessly throwing money around claiming they were going for a meta-level strategy,
and it was like a bottomless pit leaking out endlessly. Then, when it became difficult to produce anything with immediate visible results, the
stock price crashed in '22, and
around '23, I thought, 'I
think I was a bit too hasty.'  yes.  And then they drastically scaled back that business plan,
scoffing at it, and as the
stock price
recovered, it has now risen much higher.
So, Zuckerberg is always a bit
fast.
yes.  [Clears throat] From what I hear from the
people over there, they are
always faster than that guy.  So,
in a way, weren't
Meta and Microsoft the companies that spent the most on GPUs
?  You know how
Netter Micro built the most GPUs back in '23 and '24?  Right
?
And if you go down further, well,
Aliba did this much too,
so it is true that it was built the fastest.
I bought it the fastest, and I
'm buying it the fastest right now. Hey, I bought everything, but what is this?  Why aren't you making good
use of it?
And as you can see in the comments just now,
what is this Chinese company?  Dr. Manus
AI. They
say his name is Manus AI.  Meta was trying to
acquire the Chinese AI, but the central government just
told them not to do it, just not to sell it, you know?  Ah, well, the
Chinese government told us not to go.
Yes, the Chinese government
told us not to go.  So, Meta is
acquiring Manus, and there are issues with the Chinese government. Until recently,
there was a restriction on using mouse AI in the "Insights" menu on Instagram, but that has recently been
removed.
So, to
utilize it, whether you use it or not, and I was
looking at it today; there are several things open in that Google window, and
in the top right corner, it says to ask about fun
.  That's how it turned out.
So, use it a lot.  uh.  uh.
That is the part where I get that feeling a bit.
So, it seems like we shouldn't completely ignore this part either
.   yes
.
And the story I heard was that it was
5%.
yes.   The
utilization rate of AI by AI companies is
only 5%.  Well, that’s the
idea behind this kind of talk, and it’s what was in the article here
.
Anyway, I keep listening to the people on the front lines of AI, and the
story I heard three months ago, the
Anthrock style, is now completely taking off
.  I’ve heard that in the expert realm,
but what I heard recently is that they just went all out, but the
utilization is like this. They went all out where they were supposed to, but why, why, are they not utilizing it at all? They told me to
advertise that solution.
That’s what has happened recently.
Yes, that is correct.   They said it was a
story.
We will continue to check on that part
.   The
overall market
has dropped a bit, but if you
look at the 52-week highs here, there are an increasing number of healthcare
stocks.  And
regarding Vortex FB and other financial sectors, the interest rate
example
below is Allstate.
yes.  As for Allstate, I had
n't really looked into the
insurance company.
And CrowdStrike was
at a 50-week high. I
continued to rely on Palloter Networks regarding security.
So, when the YuriPropa was released, the IT
side showed a not-so-bad performance in security areas like Cloud Strike, and
oil prices fell below 70%.
All the experimental results came out well, but there is
just one thing: the international 10-year bond keeps
falling from 4.48, so I am
paying a little attention to that part.  Also, as for the rest, there does
n't seem to be anything particularly bad for the market as a whole, and the SP 500
Equals went up by 0.7 or 7 yesterday
.  So, it means the hem is a bit
higher than in medieval silk fabric
.
That is correct.  It seems that the Equalize Index is rising relatively high as the stocks or sectors expand to
areas other than IT and semiconductors
.
yes.   The
MSSI South Korea ETF is
2.89%.   Now
, let's move on to the domestic proceedings
.
[Laughs] I will
start by telling you about yesterday.   The
Hospice Index showed a sharp decline yesterday
.  It
recorded a significant decline of approximately 7.8%.   The
index has dropped to 7,800 points
.  With the
index falling by 14% even on a five-day basis, the
decline over the past few trading days has
been quite significant.  And while it seemed like the
KOSDAQ was rising recently, it
fell sharply again by 6.7% to 7% in yesterday's trading session
.  In terms of supply and demand,
individual investors purchased approximately 6.2 trillion won
.  On the other hand, foreign investors are
still continuing to sell, with
sales amounting to approximately 4.4 trillion won.   With
institutions selling in the 2 trillion won range,
[they scoffed]. Generally, when foreign investors sold
strongly, institutions would tend to absorb the selling, but
in yesterday's session, they were
selling together.   On
the other hand, there is a
continuous and strong inflow of buying pressure into foreign futures.
Generally, everyone seemed to finalize their buying at the very end of the trading session
.  That is why it seems that foreign investors are
maintaining positive futures trading
.  If you look at the trading trends by investor below, the
stocks purchased by foreign investors that day included Samsung Electronics
Preferred Stock, Reno Industrial, Hyundai Motor,
DBI Tech, LG Electronics EOTech, and
ISC.  On the other hand, on the selling
side, selling of SK Hynix, Samsung Electronics, SK
Square, Samsung Electro-Mechanics, LS1, and
Ocean
resulted in a combined sell-off of about 3 trillion won in the two major semiconductor stocks
.  During the period, we purchased SK
Square, KB Financial Group, Shinhan Financial Group, Han Aerospace
, Isu Peta, U,
Hyundai Motor, HYBE, etc.
Institutional selling included 3 trillion won in SK Hynix shares
.  There was
some strong selling pressure on Hynix from institutional investors.  Other than that, it was
Samsung Electronics, Reno, and the rest of the
ETFs.  [Clears throat] The number of
stocks hitting 52-week highs
increased to about ten, but then plummeted again,
and
only four appeared.  On the KOSPI,
Korea Kolmar and Samu Development hit
new highs.  On the KOSDAQ, Namato Construction,
Gwangjin, and Supup reached new highs.  I've noticed
that Kolmar Korea's stock
price on the KOSPI has definitely been quite strong recently.  There is a heatwave happening in Europe
right now, and I heard that it has been
extremely hot recently in Germany, and that the
utilization rate for air conditioners there is in the
single digits.  It is my first time, and I heard that it is a
country where the weather isn't that hot, but since it is so
hot in Europe right now, it
seems that companies in the sunscreen sector are getting some attention.
Why is sunscreen selling well when it's a heatwave?
Ah, but it's really hot
there, and since the penetration rate of air conditioners is low, there are
n't many.  I think Korea and
Japan make up more than 80%
.  hmm.  It's surprisingly likely,
and that's why I can't stay
at home.  It's too
hot.  They say they live in their cars, and while
we barely manage to stay at home or work,
they are in a
situation where they cannot even stay at home.   Since there are some of
our members in Germany or
Europe, please
pass on the situation there. Now, regarding foreign investors, the
combined total for SK Hynix and Samsung Electronics is about
3.1 trillion won. Yesterday, institutional investors recorded
3 trillion won for SK Hynix alone. That is correct.
Yesterday, institutions
sold off the double-trade.
Now, let's take a look at the main business division.   yes
.  Looking at the semiconductor sector first, it was a rather
rough day.  Samsung Electronics
plummeted by about 9%, and Hynix
fell by approximately 15%.
It seems like it got pushed back a bit more strongly towards the end of the session.  So, although we don't
look at memory semiconductors based on PR right now, SK
Hynix
rose about sevenfold and then came down to 5,700
.
Oh, if you take a look at the materials, parts, and equipment stocks, Hanmi Semiconductor also saw an 11% plunge yesterday.  HPSP, Wonik
IPS, Simtech,
SNSTech, Daeduck Electronics, Solbrain, and others in the materials,
substrate, and equipment sectors generally saw an average decline of about 10%, while there were quite a few
stocks that dropped by more than 20%
.  According to recent reports from the PCB industry,
memory manufacturers are currently pressuring PCB
manufacturers to lower prices
.  Well, there is talk like that,
but looking at the comments from the members,
isn't the possibility a bit low?  They were
saying such negative things.
If you look at the ITS sector, Samsung Electro-Mechanics'
stock price has also been very sluggish.   It
showed a sharp decline of 12% in the previous day's trading.
Companies like LG Innotek and others in the BH mobile value chain were also
weak.
On the other hand, the platform side was very good compared to the market
.  Naver rose 1.3
%, Kakao 1.3%, and Kakao
Bank also increased by about 5%, making the 8% increase
not bad.   The
Nikkei index fell 2.5% yesterday, and
as expected, the semiconductor sector was bad there as well
.  With Lopy Electronics dropping
7.4 to 8.5 and Disco recording a 9%
decline, and Otband also recording a drop in the 9% range, the
Japanese stock market performed poorly in sectors such as semiconductor
substrates and MLCC equipment
.  The automotive sector was
decent yesterday compared to the market.
I think there was also an impact from the significant drop in price preemptively.  Hyundai Motor fell 1%, and
Mobis and AutoEver
were also weak.
Oh, if you take a look at the consumer goods sector, Household & Health Care rose
3.8% and Amore Pacific rose 5%.
Cosmecca Korea's stock price has been
quite strong recently, recording a gain of over 4% in yesterday's trading session
.   The
skin beauty device
was relatively weak yesterday.  Classys Pharma and Hugel
AP were done.   If you look
further down, the clothing sector
also showed a good performance for the first time in a while, with sales and trade surging by about 12%.  Nongshim
surged by about 6%.  Nongshim also showed
signs of a slight rebound, and
KTNG closed 3.5% higher yesterday
.  The Eka store chain
rose a bit the day before yesterday, but it
looked like it was undergoing another correction in yesterday's session.   If
you look at the low-sweetness other sectors, yesterday,
with the exception of Hana Ocean, Hyundai Heavy Industries and
Hana Engine were generally weak.
Certainly, since engines like those from Hyundai Heavy Industries can be
seen as somewhat intertwined with the AI ​​value chain, I
think they may have been slightly affected by the decline in semiconductors.   The
steel and chemical sectors below
remained relatively flat, showing some variation relative to the market
.
Uh, looking at the trends of defense stocks below, they
seem to be doing pretty well recently.  Hanaro
rose 2.3%.  Hyundai Rotem
showed an upward trend of about 4%.
Ah, in yesterday's market too, Rhein Metal's
stock price went up by about 6% overnight.
Also, given that global defense ETFs have been
performing well recently and
showing significant gains in the market, I think we can be optimistic about defense
company stock prices today. If
you look at the bio sector below, Celltrion closed up by about 1.2% to 2%
.
[Snoring] Celltrion just announced its earnings and
recorded an earnings surprise.   hmm.
Judging by the very good results, it
seems like they are quite strong in NXT.  And if you take a look at the KOSDAQ bio
stocks below, they weren't that great, but
compared to the market, they weren't bad
.  Theogen and AB
Bio Patron were weak.
Recently, bank stocks have been performing
well again.  KB closed up about 4%, and while it seemed like
securities stocks might rebound a little, they
closed somewhat weaker in the previous session.  The entertainment side is
quite strong.  It rose to 4.6, and with GP at
4.3 and SM volume
increasing, there is definitely value merit, so it seems that
when supply and demand flow into consumer goods, there is
also movement toward the entertainment sector
.  The transformer part was a bit
disappointing yesterday.  Hyundai Electric
announced a contract worth approximately 1.2 trillion won
.   hmm.
However, after the stock price rose by more than 5% following the
announcement of a new order, it appeared to hold its ground and come back down because it is clearly
entangled in the AI ​​value chain; consequently,
stocks like LS Electric
saw a sharp decline of about 10%, and Hyosung
Heavy Industries was also weak.   So, I’ve taken a look at the
names of companies across the week
.   You
brought a report. Just a moment ago, while looking
up, I got the feeling that the era of cosmetics has
returned. You
brought a report on Amory Pacific cosmetics.  Yobo Number Researcher Course x
Y
30% Plus
Prime Day Subsidy. Even after adding
all of that up, the value is 17 times. Is
n't that too cheap? Is
it kind of like this kind of nursing illness? Yes, yes, that is correct.  I did
n't really say anything like it was too cheap, but I think I commented that it is a price range with some value merit
.  We expect the second-quarter results to be around the consensus level
.  Uh,
with sales of 1.1 trillion won and operating profit of about 100 million won, we estimated that operating profit would
still increase by about 33% year-on-year
.
It seems they expect it to come out around the market consensus level.   We
expect to record performance that exceeds existing estimates, with domestic and international sales growth rates projected to be higher than anticipated.
So, domestically, it is expected to move up
from a mid-single digit to a high-single digit year by year
.  It was estimated that Coslex
itself would likely rise by about 30% from YY 20
.  Domestic sales and operating
profit were projected to be 6 trillion won
and 6 billion won, respectively, and
operating profit was projected to be 54 billion won
.  By channel, we expect
growth to continue centered on e-commerce and MBS channels, with e-commerce increasing by 10%, multi-brand stores by 15%, department stores by low single-digit, and duty-free stores by high single-digit
.
So, depending on the inbound team, we expect to record
somewhat positive results compared to expectations for the department store or Yonsei branch channels
.
Profitability may decrease
slightly in Q due to factors such as the reflection of incentive costs associated with the closing of the fiscal year
.  And regarding money, they spoke optimistically, suggesting that the
year-on-year improvement trend might continue somewhat due to factors such as reduced labor costs and lowered discount rates
.  We also talked about the overseas sector. With
overseas sales projected at 490 billion won and operating
profit around 50 billion won, it
seems the recovery in the overseas market is quite strong.  We estimated that it would come out at 51% year-on-year
.  China is expected
to decrease by 20% year-on-year due to offline efficiency, but
profitability is projected to maintain a break-even trend, while the
Americas are expected to have grown by about 20% year-on-year
.  Oh, I hear that Seolhwansu is expanding its store presence
.   It is said that they are
also leading the growth of their core business through the growth of Innisfree and Estra.
Laneige is expected to record year-on-year flat growth in the second quarter, but
due to the Amazon Prime Day event, it is
projected to record solid growth on QQ.  It is said that Amazon's
major SKUs in the second quarter showed solid QQ growth, with Lip Cloth
Balm increasing by 73%, Lipsleeman by 24%, and
Glaze Serum by 79%
.   It
was estimated that Illiyoon also recorded positive results, with the Serum Mide Cream increasing by 140%.  And I also
expect the EMA region to be not too bad.  We projected that profitability in the Western sector would
decrease slightly due to incentive costs and investments in new brand marketing
.  It is estimated that Coslex sales will
perform well, with
high growth of 50% year-on-year in Europe and a year-on-year
growth trend in the Americas starting from the first quarter
.  It is understood that sun care products are performing well in Europe, and it
is estimated that the QQ growth rate of major SKUs in the second quarter saw significant year-on-year growth for products such as snail mucin serum, peptide eye patches, and peptide serum.  The
investment amount
was set at a target price of 180,000 won.  It is said that
during Amazon Prime Day, three Laneige Hero
SKUs entered the Amazon BT Top 100
.  It is said that 1 2 Yoon and
Cosarex have also entered.
Therefore, with earnings estimated to increase by more than 30% year-on-year, the
valuation has
become much more attractive compared to the past.  You suggested that since the current
stock price is trading at an all-time low valuation with a December forward multiple of only 17 times, it may be in a
range where the value weight has become significantly high
.   If you scroll down to
the table below and
look at the annual performance estimates for this year...
It seems they estimated that annual sales would come out to about 4.6 trillion won.  Going down to the operating
profit level, it is estimated to be around 480 billion won
.  It seems like the domestic market has been doing
pretty well recently.
Amorepacific's
cosmetics also have many
stores in the MBS channels I mentioned earlier, such as Olive Young, and
foreign tourists
often visit places like Daiso and Olive Young when they come in.  And
since people frequently visit department stores—for example, they buy high-end
Amorepacific products there and high-end
LG Household & Health Care products
at department store duty-free channels—
it seems that we are observing a trend where domestic performance is rising quite well, as foreigners are visiting and purchasing these mid-range cosmetics, such as those from Olive Young.
[Cough][Clears throat]
And the chart on the right is, uh,
Pacific's EPS and P valuation
trends.  This data has been available since 2019, and while
EPS estimates are
rising, PR continues to
decline.   The
white one is EPS.  Right?   yes
.  yes.  you're right.  hmm.  Despite the
decent trend in PS estimates,
consumer goods have been somewhat neglected recently as supply and demand have skewed toward semiconductors; however,
since the valuation is at a historical low,
earnings are not bad
.  Therefore,
looking at this chart, I
felt that even if we assume it rises only on average, there is upside potential of about 20 times from a value train perspective. However,
looking at this chart, I think that from an
investor's standpoint,
EPS has shot up sharply before, crashed,
risen again, and
fallen back down a few
times—it was a bit like the Boy Who Wept the Shepherd
.   You've been a
shepherd boy for years.   Have
you been the boy who cried wolf for seven years?  That
10 years,
almost 7 years, the bridge is long.
That's why you can't believe it.
So, usually, as EPS rises, the
stock price climbs steadily along with it, so the
PER doesn't drop
. But it's smart; even though EPS has skyrocketed, the PER drops. The
market judges that these earnings are unsustainable and takes a hit
.   It
didn't come up,
so Barton was right.  It
broke again from here.  And then it went
up again, then
turned back, but the lows are now showing
signs of rising. The EPS is
turning around this time, but is it real this time? I
can't trust it because they've done that so many times
.
But I think it's a bit different from before because the
stock prices of LG Household & Health Care and Amore Pacific were quite good in 2021. Other than that, as
trends in the cosmetics industry
shifted and companies focused on online shopping
and marketing
rose,
earnings inevitably took a sharp downturn and even multiple
de-ratings occurred, but then
EPS estimates rose sharply again from 2024 to mid-2024
.   If I
recall that time, when we
acquired Kosrex, the performance in the US sector was
really good for about two or three people.
So,
I thought we had made a good acquisition rather than considering it sustainable, but as growth in the U.S. sector took a
sharp downturn and results fell short of expectations,
EPS dropped significantly. The
valuation also took off, and just as you
mentioned earlier, people felt like they had been fooled again. However,
this time, the rise wasn't driven by major factors; rather, it seems
Yamorepacific has adapted to the trends, and as far as I
know, it has been about two years since they entered the Olive channel.  Originally, Saenggeon and Olive Hyung,
or Saenggwon, did
not stock Whoo or Sulwhasoo in the Olive Hyung area.
[Clears throat] As we enter
the market, we are
transforming into a company that fits the trends, and we are
putting a lot of effort into marketing
.  A bit different from Saenggeon.
Those aspects are now showing results, and as the
researcher mentioned earlier regarding China, they are
continuously downsizing their offline stores there.   I
think the company is changing its business direction well by reducing its exposure to China and expanding sales in the U.S. and Europe.  So, your
time in Japan wasn't bad either, so I
think there won't be any issues here that would cause the EPS to plummet like this again, as before.  Now,
Dr. Puti, you asked Dr. Wang
.   yes
.
Youngcho, as I mentioned to you, the
practical map isn't bad.  There are a lot of outflows due to the exchange rate
.   In
this case, the government offices are all dead, but since the supply and
demand for the market is very
poor, the stock price went down.
That boss also talked a lot about this kind of slash-and-burn company pattern before
.  The market is
rising and falling in the second half, so the
exact time for the second-quarter earnings announcement is right now.
Uh, the second quarter?
You have
n't announced it yet, right? Yes,
go ahead. At this point, the results can always turn out well
.  But you can always pick from that time on
.   It
continues to weaken in the second half, and the reason is that the second half's
fire jump is also very
weak,
so I think the retaining wall won't die out that much in the second half
.  It’s not bad to just tell the lathe operator to come to work when the main employee is at work
.  The economic hardship is
n't a big deal in the short term, but I'm not sure about that Chinese
marketing.  The
company speaks favorably of the shipping company.  Looking at the results, it
keeps raining.  yes.  So I do
n't know how far it goes.  You've already been through this a few
times.  I've been suffering continuously for the past few years
.  So, we need to look into that situation
.  There are
some people buying this company because its valuation is a bit low, but
compared to other companies like ARP, it is a bit weak.  Is the body the
actual torso?
Remember when Chinese tourists came in for a water rush,
we even visited the Silaote duty-free shop back then?
Right? I
think it was around 2015 when I was told to go to the duty-free shop with the extremely severe punishment I received and see Dr. Wang, but I still get a lot of them these days
.  A lot of people are coming in. I used to
say that we needed to look at what sells well at Oliver's rather than Shilla Duty Free, but looking at it now, a
lot of tourists are really coming in.  They really do come in a lot, but these days, there is
absolutely no trend of people buying things like Pacific Sohwasu or Whoo at duty-free shops.   hmm.  It’s
not that strong. Originally,
those Hong Kong wholesalers came to Korea,
mostly went to duty-free shops, and made large purchases; you know, the big country was
Hong Kong.
There's a big sale going on at Caribbean these days.  We
created a structure for shipping from Hong Kong to handle the volume of goods from the Caribbean.
So,
that's why this trend has taken off a bit.  Then
go buy it when there's a big sale.   yes
.  But back in
the day, when you bought things at duty-free shops or things like that, well, yes
.   You know, they used to
give out a lot of elevators too.
Well, they used to give up to 20% of the sales revenue, but there is nothing like that
when you buy from Olive
.   hmm.  I
probably already made the color.
No, Orbian Pixel...
can I talk about this?
[Laughs] It’s a
bit risky, but back in
the day, that Olivian could do one thing on the floor, you know
.   yes
.
Ah, if I tell you, I won't go in.  [Laughs]
Anyway, yes.  Look at this for things like that.   yes
.   yes
.
sorry.
Oh, I'm sorry.  [Laughs]
Yes.   all
right?   yes yes
.  Anyway,
Amoriper's stock has been
strong in cosmetics recently, so can I
trust them this time?
how is it?
Well, you can probably continue to receive Momunton until the earnings announcement
.  yes.   It's
good until the second-quarter earnings announcement, but it takes a
downturn after that.  If we just wait a bit for
the results, everything is already communicated.
But since the dates are 4, 5, and 6, and the second quarter is
usually treated as vacation time,
cosmetic consumption actually
increases.
Ah, because at that time, 789, we already
sent 2 units of the shipment.
Ah, since the shipment has already been sent.   that's
right.   That's true
.  If we look at clothing or similar products, like the
old Nike or Adidas English
names, it seems that performance is good in the first half of the year, and the
inventory is shipped out in advance to sell at the end of the year
.
If you look at how rarely the 789 stock price has performed well, the peak usually occurred during the second-quarter earnings announcement.
Normally, the price should have
risen significantly before that, but it
seems like it failed to rise at all this time.
That part is a little different.
Got it.
Okay, we will take a look at the products and
then move on to Samhyeong Foods.   It
seems like Samhyung Foods' stock price has been picking up a bit recently.  The trend is still a bit on
the downside, but let's take a
look at the details.  This is about the second-quarter earnings
.  This
was material from Researcher Hana Shimunju.
Uh, the estimate is that it will come out around market expectations
.  We projected sales of 720 billion won and operating
profit of 177 billion won
.  So, we expect to record a
decent operating profit with an office margin of around 25%
.  According to the Korea Customs Service,
Samyang Foods' cumulative
exports from April to May are estimated to have increased by 24% compared to the same period last year
.  According to the company, it is understood that
solid sales in the Americas and China have continued into June
. Taking this into account, it is
expected that the export growth rate for the second quarter will be around 40% year-on-year, similar to the first quarter.   We also
assessed that domestically, beef tallow ramen would contribute around 20 billion won in sales, maintaining a trend of about 100 million won per quarter.
There were concerns that rising global advertising costs, such as those from the CONCACAF World Cup, would undermine profitability, but favorable exchange rates are expected to mitigate this
somewhat.  We expect that the continued strength of both the Won and the US Dollar will have a
positive impact on the company's overall performance
.  The outlook is that while there is some base pressure in the second half, it may be
possible to level up once the Chinese factory starts operations
.  It is said that as the operation
speed of the Miliang factory accelerates, the efficiency of performance is
increasing.  It is said that Miriyang is
offsetting the shortage of work cycles following the shift change through a type of work system, and
of course, considering the initial start-up date, there is still a
burden on the base in the second half of the year
.  We expect overseas growth
to slow slightly, from 40% year-on-year in the first half of this year to around 30% in the second half
.  However, given that
another level-up is possible with the factory starting operations at the end of the year and early next year, it is
necessary to view this from a mid-to-long-term perspective.  Although it is said that the stock price has become
more attractive, the
stock price of a company concerned about the impairment of earnings in the last two quarters has
fallen to 13 times its 27-year code value.
Considering that the lower end of the band is 15 times the global peer valuation, it is said that the
short-term price attractiveness has increased
.  It was estimated that second-quarter earnings would also
come out in line with market expectations, contrary to concerns
.  Looking ahead to next year, it can be
considered an opportunity to buy at a low price.   I
predicted it.   If you look at
the performance figures, they will go down.  The projected sales for this year
are 2.9 trillion won.
Of that, overseas sales
amount to about 2.5 trillion won.  Looking at the year-on-year growth rates, domestic growth is
estimated at 12% and overseas growth at 33%.  So, although the
growth rate in overseas markets is slowing down, a
high growth rate of over 30% is still
expected
.  In terms of operating profit, it is
estimated to be around 700 million this year, which is a 34% year-on-year
increase.  So,
since the margin is 24%, it is estimated to
increase by about 1.7 percentage points compared to last year
.  It
seems to definitely have a significant impact on exchange rates.
And on the right are EPS warnings and
valuations.  Even though EPS
continues to rise, the
valuation has been continuously falling
.  I
think the valuation has room to go up to at least 18 times, with about 20 times the potential.  Of course, I do
think it will be difficult to go any higher than that,
but still, 14 times is a bit much since I've seen
distribution companies reach 14 times their value.
But I think 14 times the price is a bit too much
.  So, would
n't it be one of the most attractive options in the consumer food sector?  So,
earnings growth is projected at 30%, and considering it is a
globally
competitive company as you mentioned, wouldn't the valuation not have dropped to this level at 14 times
under normal market conditions
?   hmm.
I have that thought.
Recently, when I explain the stock market,
I often use Lee Hyung Foods as an example
.   Have some
ice cream.  When the sun is blazing and there is a
heatwave, ice cream
sells well but umbrellas don't. However,
considering the seasons in our country, we always
have a rainy season and it only rains occasionally,
so should we just throw these umbrellas away completely?   Come to
think of it, I always seem to need an umbrella.
So, when it rains, umbrella
sales go well again, while ice cream vendors
don't sell ice cream—you
often use that expression when studying Markwich's portfolio theory, right?   Right
?
yes.
So, if you look at why Markowie's portfolio theory
received the Nobel Prize, it
was a very simple paper.  It is a
paper that Markoites wrote while doing his Ph.D. and
won the Nobel Prize for. He observed that even though the return is the same 100% when investing in a single stock versus
splitting it 50/50 between an umbrella and an ice cream, the
volatility
decreases significantly.
So, even with the same profit, this
volatility can be reduced.  So,
while proving the effects of diversification, it was really simple,
so wasn't it Milton Prindmann?  What kind of
professor wrote something like this as a doctoral dissertation?  It was
really peaceful.
Yes, it would be good if we understood that concept to the extent that we could receive legal compensation later.
President Choi Bu
always brings charts like this, you know.  Right?  You should
buy when the stock price falls while the fundamentals keep rising (EPS)
.  You say this a lot, don't you?
yes.  However, if you look to the side, just as Go Ga-jang
mentioned, the sales growth rate was
44.9% in 2024, 36% last year, and 24.9% this year
. And if you look at the operating profit, the turnover rate is also very high, at 124.9%, 46.9%, and 38%.
Looking at profit growth, well, actually, it's
fine. However, the stock price is
falling from its peak to around the PR level it hit during trading. The problem is that the
semiconductor sector is just too sharp.
Export data for June was also released, but
since it increased by 199%, it is, so to speak, taking a hit
.  Uh, things were going well, but
seeing the market next door growing by 200%,
that's where the troublemakers started.
So, the relative attractiveness has dropped right now. It
seems normal for the stock price to slide sideways rather than fall, but people were thinking, "Hey, I should
sell this and buy semiconductors. What are you doing eating ramen right now?" and kept
going in that direction, which is why it has
dropped like that. And if you
think about how the earnings of the same stock will turn out next year or the year after, you wonder, "Will those
earnings actually be achieved?"  That will probably come out.
Because this woman has excellent visibility, if it
hits 3,
those who are currently investing long-term will undoubtedly think, "Am
I seeing something wrong?"
Those of you who are only looking at individual stocks might be wondering if you are
seeing things wrong, but as I
mentioned, the semiconductor market is very
strong right now.   I mentioned that
stocks like these—semiconductor [snorting]—would start fluctuating and
rising once the sunlight starts to cloud over a bit and such clusters appear.
In that sense, I
said that the stock market seemed abnormal. Yes, the stock market
always operates normally, but
there is always some herd mentality.
If you look at the public's tendency to sway, you can understand that the somewhat
irrational and
unthinking behavior is also a facet of the market
.
Okay, so you mentioned the upward trend up to the 10-minute mark, and
earnings announcements are coming out, but the outlook is to
meet market expectations.
Researcher Simunju
shared this with us.  Okay, it is 9 o'clock, and
since the night futures dropped 1.84 yesterday, it is starting today down
1.5%.
But the forecast is positive.   Yes,
the prediction is.  It is expected to start up 0.5%
.  As of now, [snorting],
accurate figures are not yet available
.   yes
.  [Clears throat]
Yesterday, KOSPI and KOSDAQ...  The KOSDAQ was
n't doing too badly at first either, relatively speaking, but it ended up getting pushed down along with it
.   Since the
beginning of the year, the Hospice has risen 81%, and
by the end of June, it had risen 101.1%,
just like it did at the start.  yes.  yes.
Yesterday, after I gave the monthly outlook, I
mentioned this.
People look at this stock, which was already rising a lot, and say that it is
truly remarkable that it was held high until it reached that level.   It is
truly remarkable that you held it up that long, but a stock that rose significantly—like
A—was at 100% and is
now at 80%, which means a 20% loss.
That is correct.  It's a 20% minus, but
actually, it's a 40% minus
.  Because it went up 100%.
So, well, 5, 10,000... since it's
become 5, 2,000, it's 100%
possible.
But only 8, that's it.   Because it
dropped 12% or 20%.  That's right.
Uh,
if it has gone up 100%, then
based on 5
, if 5 won becomes 10,000 won, that is
100%.
yes.  That's right.  yes.  yes.   It
went up 100%, but if it
drops 20% from that 10,000 won, it's like this right now
.  If it's 81% since the beginning of the year,
ah, you mean the benchmark?  So, to
put it simply, if 100
becomes 200, that means it has increased by 100%
.   If you
take out about 10% of that,
uh, 200 becomes 180, right?
I explained it well, but I explained it
wrong.  That's how it turned out.  Since the reference point
itself is set from the top, the
cumulative return appears small when viewed from below, despite the small rate of return.   that's
right.
yes.
So, if it drops 10% from the peak of 10,000 won, it's
9,000 won,
yes.
But if we look at that 5,000 as a baseline,
when it reaches 5,000, my profit
is 100%,
yes.  Uh, if it gets a lot, my rate of return has gone
from 5,000 to 9,000, so it's
exactly 80% right now.
yes.  That is correct.  yes.
So, let's say it has dropped 20% from its peak
.  It fell 20% from the peak.   In
that case, it becomes 8,000, but if you
look at it based on 5,000, it becomes 100% Nata
.
you're right.  yes.  you're right.
So, if you look at the stocks compared to their peaks, there were
many that dropped by as much as 35%, right?   It makes
them feel really disheartened. Let's
say it has dropped 40% from its peak. Since
stocks have fallen significantly by 40% recently—and
in reality, it
went from 50,000 to 20,000 won and then back down to 6,000 won—
then, damn it, a 100% profit is now reflected
as 20%
.
That is why, when you look at
stocks with high beta after reaching their peak, they
move sharply, so that is
correct.
And our country's stocks are also taking off in an instant
this time, even though they are facing heavy losses
.  It happened in an instant
.
So, the reason everyone feels the impact is so
severe is because news is coming out that what I earned is being gnawed away—giving back
double the profit—so
what do you think happened?   yes
.  The market has started.  The
KOSPI index started higher with a plus of 1.2%
.  Currently, it has
dropped slightly to 68% with a plus of 0.68%
.
And the KOSDAQ is in the negative.   yes
.  The KOSDAQ also
started higher, up 0.98%.  Currently, it is
falling by about -0.32% to 0.4%.
So, there is no US market tonight.   That's right
.  That is correct.
Yuri Pro must feel a bit relieved.
yes.  And
yes.  Yurif has been
covering the US market in the Morning Brief while Assistant Manager Soyoung was on leave of absence, but since Yurif's
internship has ended,
today is the
last day of the Morning Briefing.
However, it will be included in tomorrow's special edition.   I will
greet you one more time tomorrow, but please
say a few words for our loyal listeners who love VE.   I
learned a lot and grew over the past month, and
thank you for leaving such kind comments.   I will continue to
study the market based on what I learned at Chasley.
A month?   yes
.   I
have been working on Byeolju Bujeon for a little over two months.
Ah, I did the Byeolju Bujeon for two months.   yes
.
So, it didn't feel like a month. Since I was watching
continuously from Monday through Saturday, it really felt like
one or two months—or rather, three months
.
So, Assistant Manager Seo-hyung
went to Yugajui starting in June, and that is
correct.  yes.   I've only
been doing it for a month, but the
level was incredibly high, as if I had been doing it for several years
.
Many people are sad to see you go now,
thinking that Salt would be with us forever.
But since Yuri Pro has the weekend show "The Tale of the Starfish" and will be
appearing as a guest in between to host the show, she is
n't going far away. She'll be going to Yeouido to do
interviews at other companies and gain
various experiences. So, uh, regarding the
Korean market saying it was bullish yesterday,
oh, that's right.  Yesterday, I had a really
good fortune with my beekeeping.
Hmm,
Dr. Wang. So,
how is it today?
There is a bearish candle today.   Are
n't you feeling the same way again with the bearish candle?  Ah,
that heart is the system heart. The
system heart is not Dr. Wang's heart. It is An Bong's
heart. This
is An Bong.   You're
including the system, right?  yes.  KOSPI
moved up yesterday.  yes.  jesus.
Today is Friday and the
U.S. market is closed, but
semiconductor earnings announcements are scheduled for next week
.  So, even though it
is Friday, memory stocks are showing some rebound today.
However, since the opening price started a bit high, it is
a bit ambiguous, but I will predict a bullish candle
.  Uh,
isn't the concession the KOSPI concession?
Yes, I will keep bees.
With conviction [clearing one's throat].  Yes
[laughs]
No, Oh Ga-jeong is the successor rather than me, right?   Let's gather
.   Based on my
experience trading derivatives,
yes. When prices
drop like they did yesterday, they tend to come back up.
However, if you look at yesterday's market, for example, in the case of the market leader, people took a hit at the
8:00 opening price but bought back about
60% at the closing price. Because it
dropped so much, people become tempted to buy at yesterday's closing price
.   hmm.
But those who bought at yesterday's closing price will likely try to
sell again if it goes up today, while
those who didn't sell might think, "Yeah,
after experiencing that kind of drop yesterday, maybe I should sell if it goes up."
However, regarding foreign investor supply and demand, which is actually the
most important factor, remember how it was in July and
August of 2024?
In July and August of 2014, even though people were saying that Samsung Electronics might
pass the call test,
foreign investors kept
selling like crazy. Then, in early August, carry
traders liquidated, and
later Morgan Stanley said that a low-growth investor could appear and
move into semiconductors.   yes
.  Because of that talk, they started
dropping out from then on, starting from July. So, in April 2025, the
Trump generation hit rock bottom and turned around,
but now foreigners are already
selling off another 1 trillion won.   It
appears to be selling for around 500 million won right now.
Ah, is it 500 million?  Is this from yesterday?
About 500 million.
Uh, about 500 million.   yes
.
500 million... wait a minute.  It has
n't even been 10 minutes yet.  yes.
Fortunately, institutional investors are picking up some buying
.  It's about 64 billion now.
About 64 billion.
So, just looking at the technical signs,
I used to play a lot when long bearish or bullish candles appeared.
So, if a long bullish candle appears, I place
buy orders all the way down to minus 2% from the opening price the next day
.  Then, uh, what? It
went up a lot.  I mean, it looks like they were thinking, "I should sell some today," and because there was
selling demand in the morning, it got
pushed back a bit, but then it started to
go back up
.  Now I understand the opposite case when a long bearish candle appears
.  It is fluctuating around 7,600, and the
monthly forecast data will be
uploaded to the bus platform sometime today
.  The monthly outlook will be posted today at the cafes where our customers are located, so
please take note.   Okay
, that concludes today's Chaeseul's Morning Brik
.  Uh,
even hitting it is an investment.
yes.   If you
have conviction regarding your stock, you can just
hold on blindly. But for
those of you holding some cash, or those who are worried and wondering, "
Ah,
what should I do?"  Well, for those people, you can
prepare plenty of checks and take a break.  After going back and forth for a
month, you will find your
direction again, and since a
big market is singing again from the end of this year to next year, I
hope you manage the season well, including your mindset.
Have a happy weekend, and we will
see you at Byeoljujeon tomorrow at 5 o'clock.
Thank you.  thank you